>>Narrator: On the Kona Coast
of the big island of Hawaii,
there's a ramshackle
collection of fish tanks,
pipes and mobile housing
units that looks more
like a laboratory than a school.
The ambiance is appropriate,
because there's a bold experiment
in education underway here.
>>Teacher: I need student
helper to be in charge of this
to help me put the packets together.
>>Narrator: Instead of taking
biology, history and math,
these high school students
spend the school day working
on various projects that
encompass everything
from restoring ancient fish ponds,
to surveying reef ecosystems,
to building exotic electric
vehicles and racing them.
Opened in the Year 2000 as an
alternative public high school
for tenth through twelfth grade, the
West Hawaii Explorations Academy,
or WHEA reflects the educational
philosophy of Principal Bill Woerner.
>>Bill: Education is not a
collection of information.
Education is being able to
function well in a society.
These students function really
well, because they've learned how
to operate on small
teams, and to lay out how
to solve complicated
problems in a reasonable way.
>> Like two, three, four, five.
>> Any color, or white?
>>Bill: The little
pieces and snippets
of information they might get along
the way, that's sort of irrelevant,
that's the risk that they work with.
But the structure of how
you go about learning
and being a lifelong learner,
those are the things that, I think,
this program does very well.
>>Teacher: [speaking
foreign language]
>>Narrator: Williams 130 students
receive some traditional instruction
in math, reading, writing
and language arts.
But they earn most of the credit
for their core subjects by managing
and staffing a variety of projects.
They develop their own research
parameters, conduct online research.
And consult with mentors.
>>Student: To take sea
water, you have to bleach it,
then you have to add the sodium
phosphate, and neutralize it.
And then you can put the
algae in and grow it.
So it says...
>>Narrator: They review
their evidence portfolios
with their teachers each
week, and make a final written
and oral presentation of their
findings at the end of the semester.
>>Teacher: And see if you
can find the contact for him.
>>Narrator: While the
environment is at times chaotic,
some researchers insist that
WHEA's approach is effective.
>>Nina: I have done research
that led me to believe
that the important parts
of education are number one
that people have choice and
control over their own learning.
And number two that they're in
a collaborative environment.
And thirdly, that kids are
engaged in content worth knowing.
>>Student: Now let it sit here.
>>Narrator: These WHEA students
are restoring an ancient fish pond,
a project that combines
anthropology, ecology, biology,
community service, and manual labor.
>>Student: It's an old ancient
incline pond from back in the day
when Kamehameha ruled
the Hawaiian Islands.
And this was one of his personal
ponds that used to hold fish in.
This is where he got much of
his fish supply for eating,
and guppies were introduced
a long time ago,
and they've overrun the pond.
And we're trying to restore the pond
to its natural state,
which is pristine.
>>Student: Cleaning out this
pond is really important.
it's really important to show the
children of the future how back
in the past that these
ponds were used.
>>Teacher: He's been moved around
all day, so he's hiding in there.
>>Narrator: The projects WHEA
students participate in are as varied
as the imagination of the
students who design them.
But most have a public
service aspect,
like this ecology education
program for primary school kids.
>> C'mon, I can't breathe well.
>> She is so frightened because
she can't have a trouble-free...
>> What a cruel world!
Someone please help me!
>> What if don't want to?
I guess I could try.
>>Narrator: For new teachers
like Shari Harada-Shrai,
WHEA's project-based
learning approach offers an
exciting challenge.
>>Shari: If somebody told me when I
was student teaching that, you know,
ten months from now you're going
to be in the water snorkeling
with your kids and
taking data and trying
to explain this, I'd
be like, "No way!"
>>Student: There's a lot of
different reasons to graph,
whether it's dwarfing
and that kind of stuff.
>>Shari: And I'm learning
from my students.
And that's the real gift.
When you model, and then you show
it to your other students that,
"You know, I'm a learner, too.
Not only a teacher, I'm a learner.
And I love to learn."
Then everybody's just in a
whole learning community.
[laughs]
>>Narrator: The learning
community at WHEA ranges
from special ed to gifted.
and the project approach
seems to work well
at both ends of the spectrum.
>>Shari: This one particular student,
she decided that she wanted
to try this school out.
And at the first semester, she
just-- paperwork would come in,
but it was real sloppy, no
effort, hardly any journals.
>> Put numbers inside the tank, so
it's like one, two, three, four.
>>Shari: The second semester,
she has turned in everything.
From a research paper
to a literary critique,
to her evidence folder,
weekly paperwork.
Always asking me and
inquiring for help.
You know, just the whole motivation
turnaround is total and complete.
And she keeps telling me,
"Thank you, thank you.
I love you."
And I said, "No, thank yourself.
You did it, you pushed yourself."
>>Narrator: The WHEA staff
has developed partnerships
with local companies, universities
and community organizations
recruiting project mentors
and opening up career opportunities
for students like Jared Willeford,
who landed a job at a
nearby microalgae farm.
>>Jared: I was really interested
in what they were doing,
and I caught on really fast,
so they kind of integrated me
into the process, and now I'm getting
paid, and I'm moving up the field,
so I'll be a technician pretty soon.
In the future, maybe
if I can get a farm,
and I've already learned all the
different fertilization methods,
and things such as that, so I
could set up my own system and kind
of live off my own stuff, you know?
Pretty much live off
of what I've learned.
>>Mentor: Notice how they have
those spot patterns on their back?
That's totally unique.
>>Narrator: Mentors play a key
role in many WHEA projects.
Erin Rletow has been
studying water quality issues,
working with the staff at
the Four Seasons Resort.
>>Mentor: We do a salinity test.
>>Erin: Got about a 26;
How come it's so low?
>>Mentor: Well, it's low
as compared with the ocean,
which is about 34-35 parts per
thousand, but we keep it low
like that so that the
fish can't reproduce.
>>Erin: Compared to
books, magazines, articles,
working with mentors has
been my biggest source
of information all
throughout the three years
that I've been at the school.
And not only can you ask direct
questions, and they can answer them,
but they also give you more
than what you asked for.
>>Mentor: The lone
female, she's the biggest.
>>Narrator: Erin has been
conducting an experiment
for the past three years on a
brackish water pond at the resort
to see if the introduction of
bacteria will improve water quality.
>>Erin: I love what I do [laughs]
and it's really exciting,
and it feels good!
Instead of-- compared to being where
I was before, sitting in a classroom,
four walls, lights, textbooks, desks.
This is my classroom now
,this is where I learn.
>>Narrator: Part of the learning
process is demonstrating what
you know.
For Erin, that meant presenting
her research findings to a panel
of graduate students at the
University of Hawaii on Oahu.
>>Erin: For those of you who
aren't sure what incline pools are,
they're pretty much
landlocked brackish water ponds.
There's three characteristics
that really define a pool.
>>Erin: If you want to excel
and you want to push yourself,
there isn't any class
in a public school
that could give you what
you can give yourself,
and that's what the greatest
thing is is because it's all you.
I'm so blessed to have been able
to go to this school, it's great.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.